Trump encourages the scientists as
Candace who would only her Republican
party okay a different approach here's
what he says Rhonda Sanchez is a young
man who is not doing well against me in
the polls to put it mildly I believe
that if he decides to run for president
which will only hurt and somewhat divide
a Republican party he will lose the
cherished and massive Mega vote he's
already saying it right up front and
never be able to successfully run for
office again I don't know about that if
he remains Governor which is what
Florida voters assumed it will be a
whole different story just saying but
again who knows some people read into
this and they said
the fact that he's hinting at if you
don't run I'll have you as my VP some
are saying that'll never happen but uh
what do you think about what he just
said here about the scientists
it's one of the nicer things he said in
the last few months is not calling a
meatball Ron or Ron the sanctimonious or
you know uh peddling stories about him
hanging out with underage women so
that's that's good for him
um which there's actually some truth you
know to use some truth social in it that
that he might uh lose the massive
cherished uh Maga vote
um one of the things I actually wanted
to bring about to Sanders that you just
brought about this is some one of the
things because I've been an advocate of
saying I would vote for DeSantis have
you heard about the fact that because
you brought up abortions and how like
that's gonna potentially shoot uh
Republicans shoot themselves in the foot
especially to Suburban women or just
women across the country you know it's
supposed to be a red wave in the
midterms it ended up being like a red
like Drop in the bucket yeah
um Florida backed by DeSantis is trying
to pass a six week abortion bill
six weeks yeah you heard about this pull
this up and apparently it was approved
now listen you can debate the abortion
all you want but uh six weeks some women
you know don't even know they're
pregnant within a month the first month
and I think the stats show
um
43 of pregnancies hap of abortions
happen within six weeks 36 percent
happen between seven and nine weeks 13
between 10 and 13 weeks so I think a lot
of people have sort of used like the
12-week number as sort of a
you know comfortable number that you can
wrap your head around but six weeks so
if
back to your point about DeSantis
if that's your message that you're going
to be more of a moderate and you know
kind of not play to the mega Wing but
also uh get some of the disaffected
Liberals and Independence on your side a
six week abortion bill you think that's
going to get women to vote for you yeah
no I know Homie don't play that well and
this this is why it's it's it's always
been one of those issues right it's like
you're talking about you know reformed
entitlements right I mean every time the
Republican Party Wades into the abortion
issue you know it I I don't get how do
they how do they not look at this and go
okay you know what we got to sit down
and come up with nobody lives in the
[__] Center anymore so nobody you
don't have anybody in Washington saying
let's all sit down as reasonable people
and come up with something right that
that makes sense that both sides can
live with you have one Centrist you have
Joe manchin yeah yeah basically that's
it yeah but I don't think I don't know
that you know look if the Santos was to
be Republican nominee yeah I'd vote for
him right but
I think Trump's correct in the sense
that
you know all he's got to do is kind of
you know start that attack plan and you
know his voting base is not going to
suddenly Embrace Ron DeSantis right so
there's a I think there's a real problem
coming down the pike for the Republican
party that that you know typically
they'll just ignore for a while uh and
then you know it'll be sort of all hands
on deck and panic you know leading up to
the election and but if you're a
DeSantis you don't know what's going to
happen four or five years from now you
can't predict you know Florida might
have a hurricane it might be an absolute
mess here you never know what kind of
six-week abortion Bill all of a sudden
approval ratings go down right now his
stock is as high as ever you have to
seize the moment Carpe Diem oh yeah
because I don't think yeah you just
nailed it like think about it if Trump
runs this one and Ron doesn't nobody's
he's going to be literally could be
irrelevant it could be people just like
okay just stay in Florida like whatever
but just it's crazy though that that's
all the Democratic party has to offer
yes
unless if
Trump
does back them up 100 to run afterwards
because think about it this way say
Trump runs four years okay okay and the
sentence goes behind them I want you to
think about this uh here real quick say
DeSantis says all right I'll get
involved a little bit just to get a
little bit of experience and I'll run
and apparently he can't run until July
because he has to get his governorship
job in place before he announces that
he's running some date like I think it's
July but I think it's July so he goes in
and they duke it out for five months
whatever the time six months five months
and then within two three months okay
guess what game it's yours perfect
they talk to each other just like Ted
Cruz lined up and Ted Cruz like let's go
let's roll Trump can flip real quick if
you're gonna get his back he'll flip
right so DeSantis comes and backs them
up and they run now watch during Trump's
second term if the sentence got his back
100 percent
guess what Trump's going to do for
DeSantis Trump's going to be his number
one flag carrier and help him become
president and then DeSantis can have 12
years eight years which means it'll be
Trump to Santa's 12 years now that
doesn't mean a DeSantis Camp listen to
this they're saying oh you have no clue
what the hell you're talking about maybe
you're right maybe we don't we're just
talking guys we're not in your world and
you know and you're right about the fact
that this guy was the number one
governor in what he did above and beyond
everybody else we're in Florida because
of this guy you're from LA and New York
I'm from L.A and I lived in Texas for
five years and I like the governor in
Texas he does a great job yeah but we
moved here because it gave the balance
of Florida and Texas together so if you
like this clip and you want to watch
another one click right here and if you
want to watch the entire podcast click
right here
[Music]